hey do you have Wi-Fi here obviously we
have forgetten Wi-Fi year what is this
Bob Dole's personal officer okay so some
drinks I got this IRL and I are L being
you my name is Mark I'm pretty much the
bars web guru slash IT guy and I just
walked in for a new modem I have a very
specific set of skills like he was also
quite GaN Jin's
anyway this freaking dumb one he thought
that we could be using an 802.11 ever
heard of the point 11 and please don't
drink this we'll listen I just quit
rushing me honestly what is this Temple
Run so basically I took about myself to
upgrade the Wi-Fi name to mv-22 9 1 2 3
4 5 8 9 and it's easy to remember
because it's my initials followed by my
social but that's just the beginning of
it ok because only a freaking noob will
leave a Wi-Fi public like this ok where
am i frickin Bernie Sanders giving out
free college to everybody I'm waiting on
an important email from my boss think
you're gonna want to know the password
and so obviously I wanted a very
comprehensive and sophisticated password
but this muscle meat boy he thinks that
we should have a very easy to know
password so I made the password if
Baltimore was so freakin smart how come
he didn't have a time Turner also what
the Frick mark region is the smartest
Wizard of all time
I'll lowercase with the valves replaced
by the peach emoji ok I'm signed on
but the Wi-Fi seems super weak yeah I'm
mining crypto in the back so that checks
out barkeep another flagon of ale